[Music]
there's a man
who's now 87 years old
who hasn't washed in 67 years washed
washed and eats roadkill
okay
and is in good health sounds like
he's totally in good health yeah he's
getting
what does good health mean yeah mental
health
no like literally he doesn't have no
sicknesses everything doctors and no
sicknesses yeah he's good how much can
he bench though yeah
[Laughter]
87 years old
87. he eats roadkill he drinks from
puddles it's not basically drinks from
yours
and he smokes a pipe filled with animal
manure
the human body could adapt to anything
but why would you smoke animals
dedicated trolls it gets you higher
yeah i mean the roadkill i understand
because there is a whole movement of
like people like you don't need to wrong
kill you understand yes
but out of all the things like that at
the left they're dead already let me
tell you let me tell you right because
outside of california right they have a
lot of [ __ ] roadkill like fresh
roadkill right because they have way
more animals and [ __ ] like a nice deer
yeah you could get deer you can [ __ ]
armadillo whatever right a rib eye [ __ ]
someone ran over this
a1 wagon
but i think it started from the concept
of like they're against the uh meat
industry and there's hella
protein out there and then they're not
getting rotten meat they're just getting
fresh roadkill like oh they like oh yeah
[ __ ] check the pulse oh that
[ __ ] is dead and they're like oh
that's still warm whatever they take it
back and they cook it immediately so
it's the same thing as hunting but
they're just being vultures you know
they're like scavengers that's good yeah
so they but they cook it still yeah they
don't need to roll that's cool did this
guy eat it wrong how does he season it
this guy eats it raw this elderly man's
diet is said to consist of mainly raw
roadkill including creatures such as
porcupines and he drinks water straight
from puddles in the street yeah so i
don't think he's doing the same thing
that i did
everything back i said
his favorite pastime is smoking a pipe
filled with animal manure which has left
him more actually he's doing something
that we don't [ __ ] know because at 87
normal
uh uh you know men are [ __ ]
pumped up on pills i mean
i'd prefer not to look like this but you
know what i'm saying like yo he looks
good for 87 though low keto thriving
he's like obviously
he looks good is he really 87 87 years
old that's pretty good for
from puddles isn't there [ __ ] motor
oil in there not all the time you just
gotta find the right puddle
all the puddles i see on the street from
rainbow puddles look at that rainbow
shine to the top you know you can't
drink that or you gotta go below it so
you don't catch but how do they know
that's just not easy to drink how do
they know that he's telling the truth
because like you know people always say
like hey this is all i do and then they
get caught eating [ __ ] mcdonald's and
[ __ ] like that's very true it was a dude
who said he doesn't eat anything and he
gets all his nutrition from staring at
the sun like an hour a day or something
that's like gavin newsom
i don't wear i always wear my mask oh
everybody started practicing soul gazing
so this dude's name is uh amu jaji from
iran
uh villagers in iran have been so
impressed by his dedication to his
unconventional lifestyle that they built
him a small shack as an alternative to
his usual hole that's so nice and medics
that's really sweet like they built the
[ __ ] a shed for him that's so nice
yeah medics who visited the shack in the
village of deja iran carried out several
tests and said that despite his
lifestyle joji is surprisingly healthy
and has no serious diseases or bacteria
okay so he's is he really 87 though
because then what if he's like look at
mel gibson
those gurus that are like i'm actually a
thousand years old you know like it's
like shut the [ __ ] up dude you're not 87
and when you look at him you're like
actually he's 45 but he just says he's
87. and then that's when i'll be like
but he looks like look at him he doesn't
look like an 87 year old he looks dirty
as [ __ ] he's trying to sell this he's
trying to sell his newest
age is different
so experts were interested in
discovering different types of life
forms including parasites that might
have taken up home in his body but were
able to confirm that he does not have
any diseases or parasites despite his
lack of hygiene what wow
he might be they have parasites
but it doesn't wait it wasn't he doesn't
have it they were they were hopeful
they're expecting to find stuff like
that because of his lack of hygiene all
this crazy stuff you're gonna get a
parasite or two so in essence they're
pretty much concluding that he has just
over such a long period of time
developed such a strong immune system
that you can drink from puddles and eat
raw roadkill and be fine i think you do
that for five years you're good bro kobe
don't matter bro like most diseases
they're gonna find a coveted vaccine
through this man what kind of roadkill
do you think they get in iran
these porcupines porcupines like this
right here is an image of his lunch for
the day which is pretty much like it
looks like a dead bird
that's yeah that's he's just going to
rise all over it
never mind
and uh it's just in a bag he just leaves
it in a bag and then he just he just
eats it with the maggots and everything
he's on modern modern-day
caveman maybe the flies is seasoning
it's like furry cocky on there like you
think that's what's crazy is like flies
are always on like [ __ ] and stuff and
then it's all over this and he's eating
it i wonder what his teeth look like and
stuff oh yeah that's true
he's like what's that
i don't know how are those
this part this particular article
actually says the newfound fame for the
homeless pensioner has made life more
difficult for him
although neighbors respect him people
occasionally show up to taunt him and
throw stones that's [ __ ] up bro
fame was gonna be like they show up to
give him food and then they're like hey
[ __ ] bump
that's a hate
crime that's [ __ ] up genetics are
crazy though my grandpa he
smoked for 70 years
and uh when he passed we went from like
20 all the way to 95 when he passed it
wasn't like emphysema or lungs or
anything you know why other [ __ ] he he
smoked it like barbecue and he preserved
himself that's true yeah he does have a
smokey low and slow
slow
just cured meat on the inside
yeah no emphysema he could have been
organized he's got no cancer but he's a
jerky now
kidney or failure or whatever like liver
but his lungs were like
at 95 you're not dying of liver you're
dying of old age you know what i mean 95
is a good age yeah i i'll be blessed to
have five and you were able to smoke all
your life and you didn't die when you
were 60 something that's pretty cool and
my my mom actually thinks he's actually
older because uh when they're at that
age they didn't really have
like legit like id and stuff you know
and he came from a war-torn country i'm
like this is my dad on my on my dad's
side my grandpa my dad's side
so she was like i actually think if you
look at the pictures his like childhood
pictures is still like shaved in half
like this
all right yeah like [ __ ] like [ __ ]
ming dynasty [ __ ] [ __ ] some shanghai
noon type looking [ __ ] so my dad my
mom's like
i think he might be older than 95 does
that mean you're you're this is your
dad's grandpa that was my dad's dad your
dad's dad but my dad's oldest brother
um was like 20 years older than him
oh got seven brothers and sisters that
mean does that mean your grandma had to
do the like foot thing like the small
foot binding on that side
no on that side
no actually i don't know
i don't know because that was like that
same error they made them horny
the foot binding dude that made dudes
horny back then kind of but it also made
the women like have huge back problems i
know it's gross
yeah
but those dudes used to [ __ ] oh my
god like that was like they're in their
lips yeah they bite their hair they're
like oh
feet oh damn the chinese construction
worker like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
throws his hair around oh [ __ ] what's up
sweetheart that's how the boners are
[ __ ] brains like
here they start buying it
oh she's so fine can you imagine being
95 how like annoyed you are at the whole
world yeah like i'm not even 40 yet and
i hate everything
that's betty white right there dude
she's like [ __ ] into 100. this world
sucks
my mom asked my grandpa because all he
did was read the newspaper and i was
like i'll come read the newspaper like
all day and he was like because it's
quiet here
like it's just me and my thoughts
95. you don't gotta worry about [ __ ] you
know actually
this guy right here from iran the 87
year old also kept himself up to date
with current events and discussed events
like the russian revolution and french
revolution with those that visited him
wow so so he ain't like a crazy skid row
homeless dude nobody said ain't crazy
for any homeless person that's that
chill that's tight yeah he he just minds
his own business he's a pensioner so he
he's collecting checks yeah
what's his appeal
box what was his previous life in john
like what was his what was he doing like
working for the iranian tax collector
he's super rich in his previous life so
he's like [ __ ] this man and you put this
guy on fear factor he's going to be the
[ __ ] champion forever he should be
the host
and he should not show don't eat that
no why are you eating the box we need
that for the next guy
no you're just supposed to touch it
he's like touch it i thought i'm
supposed to eat everything he probably
goes to the crafty's table
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]